In the beginning
everybody's excited. In the beginning
everybody's going to become a billionaire. In the beginning, everybody's gonna conquer the world, but
After a few weeks a few months maybe you in a few years
They start to get tired. They start to get frustrated. They start to ask
Why is this so hard they start to ask?
Why is this so hard for me and they think it's just them and they take the whole
Fucking universe is coming down on them
And that's when people quit and guys we all feel that way
We all have times of frustration. We all have times of anger
We all have times of "why me". Why is this so hard for me?
but at the end of the day guys
When you start doing that massive frustration that massive anger that massive
Irritation and massive stress you are about to have a breakthrough
and a longer journey
And becoming great at anything
You're gonna have these curves appear over and over and over again
To make changes in any organization you have to have a measure of very high persistence
And you've got to go on and on and on and on
We don't have that persistency very often you fall of this when success is around the corner
You took the acting classes and uh, yeah, yeah, I took acting classes even in my acting classes I couldn't get a part
That
You know, the much-vaunted Twitter was a failure complete failure for two years
Nobody used it
And if they took the mindset of well, if it doesn't work in two weeks we got to go do something else
You never would have heard of them
You know why people do what they do
The people who go after this step what makes it worth it. It's got to be your passion
You got to love it. Ladies and gentlemen
You got to love it. It's got to be what you are supposed to do
You want to sing even though they want to invite you to Carnegie Hall?
You gonna say to anybody that listened to you include sing it to yourself?
I used to talk to my plants when nobody else would listen to me
You gotta ride, even if no one published your book right because that was given to you to do
You do what it is you supposed to do. You supposed to build something you supposed to create something? I don't know how to do it? Learn!
Do whatever is required
Just go out there if she was telling you you got to make that happen
Nobody's gonna bring it to you on a silver platter ten. Here's your dream manifest it
One of the things that happens especially when you're starting out is you write stories and you send them out
In my head
As a young man whenever I would send out a story what I would expect to have happen
was
the following morning a limo
Which show up at my house and
People would get out of it and they would say this is yours we loved your story so much
You never have to work again. Just thank you
thank you for writing this story which we are going to publish and make sure everybody in the whole world reads and and
Instead, you know
Six weeks later it would come back the little slip
Saying not quite right for us
But really I kind of dealt with it by just
Bowing to myself, but you know, I would try and write things that were so brilliant that nobody could
reject
The right from the beginning you must you see make up your mind
Doesn't matter even they take millions of bills bills of yours none
After all, what is the purpose of our life
the meaning of existence
nothing
You realize something?
positive
then even you see there is and mondo your
It is meaningful once you involved or dedicated or determine practice
You need to have practice to have apprenticed for 10,000 hours before you get good
So every great classical composer without exception composes for at least 10 years before they write their masterwork Mozart
10. Mozart is composing at 11, but he's composing
Garbage at 11. I mean he doesn't produce something great until he's 22 or 23 concerto number nine. I think 271
And you know you just have to show up or show up so often
Time out of the time you got to wake up
You got to drive you got to be driven to to go get something done now
You know Xan and you got to be willing to stand on your stand on yo
Yo beliefs, cuz a lot of times you're the only one who could see it you did and other people they don't see it
Really?
But you gotta really believe in what you got inside of you is telling you and driving you to a certain goal for something
I can do it
Perseverance is a hard work you do after you get tired of doing hard work you already did
You resign yourself to writing lots and lots of rubbish
You just got to write that out of your system and sooner or later. You're hit what what you know you really?
should be doing and what is your genre and
perseverance you've got to persevere because it is a it's a
Career with a lot of knock backs, but the rewards are huge. I don't mean
In the sense that if that's what you really want to do to be able to do it life long is the best thing in
the world
You will fail at some point in your life. Accept it. You will lose you will embarrass yourself you will suck at something
In the acting business you fail all the time, but here's the thing
I didn't quit
I didn't fall back
I walked out of there to prepare for the next audition and the next audition and the next audition. I pray
I pray and I pray
But I continue to fail and fail and fail
but it didn't matter because you know what is an old saying
You hang around the barbershop long enough sooner, then you're gonna get a haircut. I
I found a job I love. That's not how it works
Both of those things require hard work. You are in love because you work very hard every single day of your life
to stay in love
You find a job that brings you ultimate joy because you work hard
Every single day to serve those around you and you maintain that joy, it's not a discovery
But the problem is the sense of impatience
It's as if an entire generation is standing at the foot of a mountain. They know exactly what they want
They can see the summit what they can't see is the mountain
This large immovable object
One of the greatest probably the greatest rock climber of this generation is you know
I've been a climber most of my life Tommy Caldwell who is
is in a category of what I was out climbing with Tommy one day and I said to him
Tommy what makes you different? He's erecting of six climbs on El Cap that have never been repeated
Okay, he's just he is 10x in extreme environments.
I said Tommy, what is it that you have? You're not necessarily more physically gifted
You're not necessarily stronger
my ears certainly physically gifted all those things, but you're not this
Incredible athlete that that just was born this way
and in fact
He had lost a finger in an accident he cut a finger off and so he's doing this minus one of his
an important finger
and
He thought about it for a long moment. He said I
Can remain focused on and suffer for the big thing longer than anyone else.
And I think that's what did you obey the curiosity keeps me
well
But once they get their hands on what they see is the thing
They don't let go and they can stay with it and suffer for it
The world ain't all sunshine and rainbows
It's a very mean and nasty place and I don't care how tough you are
It will beat you to your knees and keep you there permanently
If you let it. You me or nobody is gonna hit as hard as life
but it ain't about how hard you hit it's about how hard you can get hit and keep
Moving forward how much you can take and keep moving forward?
I love basketball so much. I love planning. I just never thought I could make it to college NBA
Or stand up here today and find you guys to be NBA MVP
So many people believed in me when I didn't believe in myself
So many people doubted me and
Motivated me every single day to be Who I am. I
I fail so many times and got back up
I've been through the toughest times with my family
But I'm still standing.
I watched my wife when she got diagnosed
I watched my wife have terrible days and she probably missed two days of work the whole time. She had MS
I watched her go to work and I'm like boo. Why in the world would you get up and go to work?
You don't even need the money
Not what you do it is cold
His ten degrees in Michigan and your MS flare-up when it's cold. What are you doing? She said I can't see my daughter
I can't have my daughter to see me weak
Cuz my daughter gonna be married one day and my daughter gonna face
Tragedy one day and I have to show her how to do it
So I get up and get dressed and I'm gonna work every day
So my baby girl can know how to get through trials
Cuz one day she ain't gonna be under our roof and she don't have to do it alone
And I don't want to talk. I want to model what it looks like
Am I doing I got on the prayer line
She's a prayer meeting up today told her testimony so high you feel like going to school
I feel like walking a mile to go to class and I thought about it. My mom got a chronic illness and
Then my mom in her forties can get up with a chronic illness and go to work while surely I can get up at 18
Years old and go to class
It worked
I've had a lot of people try to tear me down
But I'm here
and I've always been myself and I've always wanted that and I've been
Graceful, and I've tried to handle myself with as much class and it's only because I know how hard I work
And I'm not gonna let any it back into me
Seed
has to be planted a
Seed got to have dirt put on top of it
If you take a seed and throw it on the concrete and walk off the Sun just burn it up
But guess what?
Logically in my mind. It doesn't make sense that to grow something
You should dig a hole put it down in there and cover it with dirt
Logically that don't make no sense to me but odo
See dirt is necessary for growth and development
Dirt builds character
Dirt gives you the push through factor
dirt makes you come with it when you don't feel like coming with it no more and you get dirt in a lot of
Different ways all the other had dirt fold on you dirty ain't always what you want
It's somebody talking about you down on your job
It's somebody accusing you or something that you didn't do
It's somebody telling you you ain't gonna make it is somebody shared information about you that ain't true
Got everybody get dirt put on but see when you getting put under that stress
Please know God is always working Kurt Franklin song. God is always working
So I smiled because I know he back there see that dirt builds character in you when they talking about you it
Teaches you to withstand it
Then it gives you something to push through
So when you put the seed and you put the dirt on it. If you understand stress, stress really ain't just dirt stress
See, they don't call it dirt when they plant it. They call it soil
Because soil has nutrients in it
But the nutrients we're people talking about your dog and you lying on you back by stealing from you talking about you
They're actually putting nutrients
Everything you see above ground that blossoms and plants and grows and that's beautiful. It was underground one time
So you want to be successful? Well, then you got to prove yourself. You got to push through the dirt
One thing I've learned over the years for my coach that the last one is the most important one
That's why they improve so if you run you got 16 here and 5 and here's tired you dying
You got it even take one
Take a little bit more time. Take one more minute and go because that's when you started proving
That's when the work pays off now because your legs are dead and you got to push your body
You got over comments like you're moving past a barrier or more moving step forward
A lot of people just want to stop because they're dead tired. If I do that extra one, that's when it improved
The song a champion is just one
who can come out at the last minute of the cozaar show and say the star closes show a
14, 15 round fight and it's even and that usually this
Champion, you can depend on him to come to the last few seconds and find some it
absorbs
marks bits this Olympic track star was mentioned
He wasn't that much greater than all the people in the world was some time. He won by just that much
Every single champion is the same as every ordinary person knowing differentials that they show up to the event every single day
They see failure as a learning curve. They welcome failure. You learn more from failure than you add the world through success
So showing up and getting knocked on your ass finally test 140 to stand back up Andrea. They said endeavour
It's gonna be the overriding factor that makes a difference
how do you know when you're doing those things the small things in life add up to those big monumental things when I say the
Small things it's a character building block that your name means something you hold value to your name if you drop trash on the ground
You pick it up. That's the responsibility you hold value to yourself when you shake someone's hand
You look them in the eye give them a firm handshake cause you're here for a purpose
Everything you do you do to the best of your gaudí
Doesn't know what you're doing is the fact that you're doing it
so therefore it means something to you because you know the title out there doesn't mean
You win the title fine, that title will not get to another title what you're trying to build its legacy
Thank you so much for watching believe nation. This is a continuation of my belief film series
I would love to know what do you think of this version?
What do you think about the changes that we made on this episode?
Any thoughts any room to it for improvement anything you want to add? Please leave it down on the comments below
Thank you so much for watching. I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in yourself and whatever your one where it is. Much love. See you soon
If you tell yourself a story long enough, you start to believe it won't you believe it? You act like I am Tulsa
What a whale out of handcuffs lightning though Thunder in jail. Now, you know, I'm bad over the last week
I murdered a rock into the stone
Hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make medicine sick
the fundamental key to success is it can take between 18 and
254 days of taking action for a new habit to stick
I've created a new course called 2:54 confidence or every single day for
254 days
I will be sending you a video between 30 seconds and 5 minutes long that you start your morning with around making you feel
confident.
It's absolutely free. Check out the link in the description below to get access